- When you see a black or
latino youngster, particularly
on the street, you walk to
the other side of the street.
- He should be worried about
the fact that there is actual
thuggish behavior taking place.
(A mix of undistinguishable voices)
- The parents of black and
latino youngsters, particularly
to not let their children
go out wearing hoodies.
- It's ridiculous.
Everybody owns hoodies.
- It's weird that I have
to like think about like
alright man, I'm going out to this thing.
Should I be wearing a hoodie
or should I try to wear a
button-up and try not to give off
that vibe of danger to anyone.
- If I wore like a straight
red shirt and like red shoes,
my mom would not let me go
out of the house, you know,
because she thinks that I'm gonna be
perceived as a gang banger, whatever.
- MLK had on a suit when
he got shot, you know.
We've worn different articles
of clothing our entire lives.
It doesn't make you less of a
victim cuz of what you wear.
- It's different.
For us, it's not only just for
like job interviews and stuff
like that, it's going out at night, it's
going to bars and stuff like that.
- My style is comfortable
without looking like Steve Jobs.
I'm not gonna walk around
wearing like a turtleneck.
- First time that I was
really called a nigger,
me and a few of my boys, some girls
invited us down to some high school show.
Now, we didn't know that she is the
only black girl in this high school.
So we go down to her
school to see this show,
and as we're sittin' there
watchin' it, we heard somebody
yell, "Who invited the niggers?"
I was like, what?
They can't be talking about
me, I'm wearing a polo.
- I feel like that the
hoodie thing is an excuse,
you know what I mean, it's
easier to say it's the jacket
that you're wearing than the
skin color of the person.
- I just started wearing
like baseball caps
because if I wear it, like
I like wearing 'em low.
If I wear a baseball cap low in a car,
I'm gonna get pulled over easy.
It's not even a question.
- I've always had hoodies.
I've never been told I couldn't
wear one for a certain reason.
I'm aware of how it may be perceived,
but that's not my fault.
The way that it's perceived has
nothing to do with who I am.
(sad music)